hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
la entrevista de france 24 en español en
esta oportunidad nos acompaña manuel
vásquez 6 y 2 el es docente e
investigador activista por los derechos
de la población el eje bético y también
ex subdirector del centro nacional para
la educación sexual de cuba cenesex con
él vamos a dialogar sobre el código de
las familias que de ser aprobado en cuba
podría generar cambios históricos en la
isla algunos de ellos para el colectivo
el eje bético manuel muchísimas gracias
por tu presencia en la entrevista de
france 24
gracias otra limitación no por favor
gracias a ti una vez más bueno aclaramos
ante todo que cuando estamos hablando de
un código de familia nos referimos a lo
que son las principales disposiciones
jurídicas en materia de derecho de
familia que tiene un estado y cuba está
debatiendo un código de las familias o
sea que no habla nos habla de familias
en plural y no de familia estamos ante
un cambio de paradigma a verdad qué
implicancias tiene esto
es correcto si cuando hablamos
justamente de que la propuesta se
inscribe en esa lógica plural y diversa
de las familias y no de una sola manera
de ver este fenómeno el fenómeno
justamente de las relaciones sociales y
jurídicas que se dan en los contextos
familiares y justamente es un cambio de
cara de paradigma que está en
consonancia con una regulación
constitucional que es justamente ya de
alguna manera anunciaba esa ruptura con
la lógica anterior o con el paradigma
anterior de observar las dinámicas y que
se dan en los contextos familiares
estamos hablando de una ruptura de
paradigma que implica no sólo contemplar
las complejidades de las familias que se
separan de las estructuras
heteronormativa sino también dentro de
las familias que se que se pueden
comprender como familia dentro de la
norma heterosexual también muestran una
multiplicidad importa una pluralidad
importante en cuanto a las maneras de
constituirse las maneras de funcionar
las maneras de eso de organizarse como
familia y realmente es un cambio de
paradigma que va a implicar que las
diferentes ciencias no solo las ciencias
sociales sino todas las ciencias que
observan a las familias como digamos
como como objeto de estudio
pues que también se plantee en las
maneras de observar los fenómenos que se
dan al interior de la familia yo creo
que las ciencias sobre todo las ciencias
sociales van a tener que replantear la
manera de las propias apoyaturas
teórico-metodológicas desde las cuales
observan las realidades familiares e
interpretan también las realidades
familiares yo creo que esa es una de las
cuestiones más revolucionarias que tiene
este proyecto del código de esa ruptura
en términos de paradigmas teóricos
metodológicos que pudiera parecer algo
sencillo hablar de familias pero
definitivamente es un cambio importante
que insisto ya venía anunciándose desde
la constitución hablar en un término
plural para referirse referirse a las
familias e incluso en la pauta
constitucional de consagrar a todas las
familias a todas las configuraciones
familiares y entre todos estos cambios
de paradigmas es tan importante que
estás comentando a manuel una es la
apertura hacia el matrimonio igualitario
verdad
es que justamente agua a ese ese es uno
de los elementos en los cuales radica
este cambio para ahí no sea observar las
las particularidades que implican las
familias que están constituidas por
personas sexualidades nuestras
normativas todo sexual con personas con
sexualidad en un hegemónico o sea yo
creo que está entrada en el ámbito
público específicamente en el ámbito
jurídico familiar de las familias no
heterosexuales a las familias a una
afectiva es una de las digamos de las
particularidades en esa ruptura de
paradigma y es una de las
particularidades de pluralizar el el
término efectivamente las familias
digamos conformadas organizadas y
estructuradas alrededor de familias de
personas con sexualidad es nuestro
normativas con independencia de que
formalicen el matrimonio y no o no pero
justamente la institución matrimonial
también
se expande o contempla la posibilidad de
que puedan ser o sea que pueda ser una
institución jurídica para que puedan
acceder personas nuestros ocho ahora
manuel entre la cerca de 70 normas
jurídicas que se van a actualizar con
mejor dicho que se están actualizando no
en cuba este código es el único y tiene
una particularidad va a ser aprobado
mediante un referendo verdad y hay voces
que están criticando esto usted porque
cree que es el único que era por esta
vía del referendo y si considera que
esto puede quizás perjudicar su
aprobación
mira yo creo que estamos hablando
justamente esta entrevista está
aconteciendo en el mismo momento en que
ha culminado el proceso de consulta
popular que yo creo que también es otro
de los elementos que han caracterizado
el proceso de reforma del del actual
código la familia y lo que es lo mismo
la presentación de este proyecto de
código de las familias estamos estamos
intercambiando criterios después de que
ha acontecido un proceso de consulta
popular cuyas cifras aportan datos muy
interesantes estamos hablando de un
proceso de consulta en el que
participaron más de 6 millones de
ciudadanos y ciudadanas y se produjeron
un número importante de intervenciones y
más del 60% de esas intervenciones de
esas propuestas que fueron colocadas
como parte de este proceso de consulta
pues resultan favorables al proyecto de
código de la familia o sea en este punto
un poco
no no sería muy ostensible pensar nos en
un referendo
negativo para un proyecto de ccoo de la
familia de lo contrario ya pues los
elementos negativos hubiesen ido
aflorando desde el proceso de consulta
popular esa es una manera de observar el
asunto ahora mismo no pudiera ni
siquiera predecir lo que va a suceder en
el referendo pero sin lugar a dudas la
información que ha arrojado el proceso
de consulta es una información
digamos positiva en términos de como las
ciudadanos y los ciudadanos han
comprendido las propuestas que integran
el proyecto de código las familias sobre
todo aquellas propuestas que se vinculan
con los derechos de las personas como
sexualidades no no es de lo normativo
efectivamente sería la única norma que
se aprobaría
o referendos y hay criterios han
existido disímiles ham hay quienes sean
y han manifestado
su desacuerdo en el sentido de que se
estaría llevando los derechos de una
digamos de minorías a referendo yo eso
no es un criterio que yo no abrazo mucho
primero porque no estamos hablando de
que se lleve a referendo un grupo de
derechos que forman parte de la
propuesta se estaría llevando referendos
toda una norma jurídica que es
importante se ponga sobre la mesa no
sólo aborda los derechos de las personas
puedan sexualidades noventero normativa
y lo otro es que no no me gusta mucho
tampoco el abordando abordarlo desde la
perspectiva de las minorías yo creo que
esta es una propuesta de norma jurídica
de todas las personas por donde quiera
que lo observen yo hay una vinculación a
los derechos de todas las personas va
más allá como bien decide los derechos
del colectivo lgtb bueno el contarnos
cómo es ser activista por los derechos
el eje vete en cuba y cómo ha ido
cambiando lo que es el tratamiento
oficial no de la homosexualidad de las
orientaciones y de las identidades
disidentes por decirlo de alguna desde
el inicio de la revolución hasta ahora
a ver qué bueno me haces una pregunta
que casi es una tesis de doctorado mira
yo yo te puedo compartir mi experiencia
personal que además ha sido una
experiencia muy particular porque ha
sido parte de insisto de una experiencia
que sobre todo ha tenido ha tenido una
historia en cuba que ha sido un
activismo que ha que ha existido
criticado pero ha existido muy
relacionado con la lógica institucional
o sea yo yo me formé como activista tuve
conciencia como activista a partir de mi
vinculación al centro nacional de
educación sexual cenesex que es una
institución estatal y la mayor parte de
mi activismo la desarrolle es justamente
como como parte de esta institución y
también compartir con colegas activistas
de una trayectoria importante que han
desarrollado su alpinismo muy vinculado
en diálogo con no sólo con esta
institución estatal sino con otras
instituciones estatales y otras
instituciones de la sociedad civil no sé
mi experiencia ha sido esa ha sido una
experiencia ligada a este activismo que
incitó ha sido criticado porque también
de alguna manera se pretende y legitimar
la posibilidad de ejercer un activismo
en diálogo que no significa que sea un
activismo a crítico en relación a la
gestión del propio estado de la gestión
del propio gobierno pero que sí
definitivamente es un activismo que
apuesta por el diálogo con las
estructuras políticas sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta que este puede ser un
elemento que amplifique las voces desde
el activismo y que de alguna manera
potencie el digamos el tratamiento
político de las demandas que se colocan
sobre sobre la mesa de diálogo en ese
sentido te digo es ha sido más permear
en mi experiencia hay probablemente
otras tantísimas experiencias yo creo
que otra de las cuestiones que me
comentaba tienen que ver con la
visibilidad de como como se observa o
como cómo ha ido ubicándose en el
contexto político cubano es justamente
las existencias de las personas con
sexualidades no de la normativa es ha
sido un proceso porque además me
comentaba desde 59 a la actualidad
habiendo transcurrido más de 60 años no
ha sido un proceso uniforme no ha sido
un proceso tranquilo no ha sido un
proceso calmo ha sido un proceso que
muchas personas han catalogado como un
proceso es digamos complejo como un
proceso con contradicciones
contradicciones propias de un proceso
revolucionario que aún está en
desarrollo un proyecto social y político
que por supuesto todavía pugna en su
construcción y yo creo que también es
tiene que ver con las contradicciones
propias de los procesos que persiguen el
logro de la justicia social sea ha sido
un tránsito de la invisibilidad a
visibilidad ha habido un tránsito de
incluso la invisibilidad en términos de
políticas públicas a la visualización en
documentos tan importantes como el plan
de desarrollo económico y social ha
estado en 30 desde mi punto de vista es
la concreción más palpable de la
voluntad política del estado y uno de
los elementos que se ubican justamente
es el enfrentamiento a toda forma de
discriminación incluyendo las
discriminaciones por orientación sexual
identidad de género
por sexos por por género y cuando
hacemos un paneo muy rápido por las
normas jurídicas o las principales
transformaciones que se han dado en los
últimos 15 años pues tenemos
modificaciones en el ámbito laboral y la
introducción de la no discriminación por
orientación sexual este mismo que de
hecho fue previo al pedestal al plan de
desarrollo económico social hasta 2030
los propios objetivos del trabajo del
partido comunista que introduce la no
discriminación por orientación sexual y
en ese caso no se ubica la identidad de
género sin embargo en el pene se ubica
si manuel bueno hemos llegado al final
de esta entrevista se nos acabó el
tiempo muchísimas gracias ha sido un
placer dialogar contigo
al pasar gracias a ti nuevamente a
nuestra audiencia como siempre le
invitamos a que siga informándose en el
resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]